the illusions are mind-boggling not just
because they're nearly perfect but
because they're actually on a body
Maryana Milosevic nicknamed [ __ ] has
seen her YouTube channel get millions of
clicks by viewers worldwide she set up a
little studio in her apartment in
Smederevo 50 kilometers from the Serbian
capital Belgrade
she liked to draw as a child and taught
herself to paint today illusionist
videos are her trademark I love
challenges and that's why I choose to do
illusions and it's very out funny when
you make a nut a knot in your stomach or
you are I'm enjoying to do this because
every day I'm someone else
Kika launched her own video channel in
2016
her international breakthrough came with
wooden puppet doll a video that won her
a top makeup artists award in Serbia she
also made an appearance on Spanish
television more than 130,000 fans have
subscribed to our YouTube channel and
regularly watch her videos she can't
believe her luck I'm so happy I am with
all people you know from all over the
world and we're talking and when they
write kisses from Brazil kisses from
France I have that feeling that I was
there or I am there you know so it's
it's a very special feeling my mother of
two in her mid 30s she makes a living
from her channel posting two new videos
a week she gets feedback from near and
far she can read the comments written in
Spanish what you do is spectacular
you surprised me every time I wish you
all the best carry on silento Sica
creciendo which is this video alone has
been viewed more than 4 million times
but [ __ ] still worries about our posts
will be received thinking ok what if
people don't like it or what if they
like it you know
and I'm wondering all the time and when
video is alive I can't watch it and I
ask my colleague and my friend ok can
you can you please
Kika can spend two days preparing her
designs scrutinizing them in the mirror
to see what works and what doesn't like
the knot on her stomach she can work on
a new body painting for up to eight
hours drawing inspiration from music and
her own experience I had a problem with
my weight and I couldn't eat I lost my
appetite and I felt that my stomach is
in a knot
you know the tricky part for the makeup
artist is holding her breath for long
stretches while she paints in the fine
details all her works of art involve
magic of some kind and Blackwall
[Music]
the bodypainting illusionist can do more
than tie herself into knots she can put
a spring in her belly it was part of her
wooden puppet illusion one of our
biggest challenges so far that spring
gave me so much trouble because it's
very difficult to paint on your stomach
on your skin on stomach because you
can't move if you want to make picture
very good and perfect
Kika is motivated to keep perfecting our
body paintings by her dream of what the
future could hold my dream is one day to
be on a red carpet and called Oscar
Hollywood may or may not be on the
horizon in the meantime she's busily
creating body painted art and tutorials
for her fans among those who've shared
Kiko's videos is American actor Charlie
Sheen but she remains dedicated to
perfecting her art and she certainly
isn't the type to lose her head over her
success
you